[Music]
a very busy weekend for metro police
some of the area commands around the
valley taking
28 impaired drivers off the roads and
that was just on saturday
but you know what even with all those
arrests officers are still investigating
several
deadly crashes we'll start with this one
a pedestrian killed after being hit by a
car on the east side near lake mead and
land this is around nine o'clock last
night
according to police a car driving west
on lake mead ran into the pedestrian
and then drove off the victim taken the
hospital pronounced dead
a man was hit and killed on sahara near
6th street earlier last night
police say he was hit by a white ford
pickup that other driver took off after
the crash
the man was taken to the hospital where
he later died police have not made any
arrests yet in that case
also yesterday morning a man was hit and
killed on the 15th near gene
nhp says he pulled over onto the left
shoulder of the freeway
and went to the northbound side to get
some of his belongings
when he was hit by a honda crv the man
died on st
john north of las vegas up in knight
county the sheriff's office there
investigating another deadly crash here
are some pictures of it
happened on u.s 95 north of beatty
nevada highway patrol says a semi truck
and a car were involved investigators
say one of the vehicles was going the
wrong way
nye county and nhp though have not given
any other details
it's 506 saturday night one person died
another was injured in a three-car crash
near decatur and
twain metro police say a man lost
control of his car
clipped an suv then speared into
oncoming traffic
and he died the other drivers involved
should recover from their injuries
nate there was some incredible video of
a violent crash near downtown
this was on cashman center saturday
morning left a pedestrian critically
hurt metro police say two suvs crashed
one driver ran a red light and jumped
the curb
and ran right into the guy on the
sidewalk and that was some gruesome
video